today you've set out your energy plan to
specifically help businesses just
explain to us the policy and the idea
behind it
well essentially we will provide for
businesses the support that we've
provided for domestic gas and
electricity users and indeed people on
heating oil that is to ensure that
prices remain at an affordable level now
domestic users it was relatively
straightforward because there was
already a price cap and their relatively
small number of suppliers the business
Market is much more complicated and
therefore we have had to come up with a
solution that caps wholesale prices
which will feed through to the
non-domestic sector and that includes
Charities and Care Homes hospitals and
schools as well as businesses
and the freeze that you've introduced
today lasts for six months you know if
you're a head teacher or a hospital
manager really worried about what
happens if Energy prices remain as high
as they are now in six months time what
reassurance can you give them
the reassurance I would give is that yes
it is announced for six months but there
will be a review in three months to see
how the scheme is working we've
introduced very rapidly a very broad
brush scheme that is covering every user
of energy with actually The Only
Exception being
gas fired power stations they're the
only exemption from this help for
obvious reasons what we want to do is to
review how it's working see whether that
is the right approach to support whether
it should be more targeted but I think I
can give some reassurance that at these
levels the government is very well aware
that schools hospitals hospices Care
Homes and many businesses would not be
able to cope with the level of fuel
prices that we currently have okay that
does give a general sort of indication
about your thinking on it
the other question I have is about how
it's going to be paid for what costings
have you done
well these will be announced by the
chancellor in the fiscal event on Friday
so I don't want to preempt him but this
is a very expensive scheme
this is the right thing to do because
the cost whether it falls on the
taxpayer or on individuals and
businesses is very substantial it is a
substantial cost for the whole economy
but the unfortunate truth is that if
this were to fall on individuals and
onto businesses many would not be able
to afford it businesses would not be
able to continue in operation but the
government shoulders are broader and
stronger and that in a sense is what
government is for is to pick up the
burdens that individuals cannot bear and
that is what we're doing the cost would
hit the economy one way or another
anyway but it's being taken on
collectively rather than falling on
individuals and non-domestic users you
don't have to say it's quite interesting
listening to you talking about the broad
shoulders of the government to you you
know Jacob Reese morgue you know and
again Liz truss is someone who spent the
leadership election telling us that she
was going to govern like a conservative
and yet really she's announced one of
the radical State intervention policies
the kind of thing that would make Jeremy
corbyn blush
well you have to think what is the state
there for fundamentally and it seems to
me that the state should lead leave us
alone to lead our own lives as much as
possible
but there are certain things that
individuals cannot do for themselves and
that may be law and order it may be the
fount of the realm but in this
circumstancing it is bearing a burden
that has because actually a Putin's
illegal uh War become unbearable so the
state is there when the individual can't
bear the burden and otherwise of course
it should lead leave the individual to
get home with his or her own life so I
think this actually fits a fundamentally
conservative view of the role of the
state it's the
um uh last um
bearer of burdens
Cornwall Insight reckons that it could
cost 25 billion pounds is that in the
right region
you're trying to tempt me to prevent the
chancellor and I think that would be
discourteous of me I I must leave the
chancellor to make his announcement on
Friday understood now Liz truss has also
said that this is a government all about
growth we know the tax cutting agenda
that she wants to set out do you think
there's also a case for looking at
employment law perhaps scrapping the
48-hour week
well I think we should look at
regulations particularly in the context
of retained EU law to see what
regulations are suitable for economic
growth and which ones aren't we now have
the freedom to decide that and that's
one of the benefits of brexit but it's
too early to announce any specific
policies but I'm looking forward to the
retained EU law bill being introduced
into Parliament shortly which will have
a expedited process for appealing
unnecessary EU laws do you think that
the 48-hour week then could be an
unnecessary EU law
um well you said that not me I I'm I
think it's certainly something that
people will raise I don't want to
preempt decisions that haven't been made
um but we have to look at whether we
have the right system of regulation in
this country to maximize economic growth